our first report tonight is from our
political editor Beth Rigby and a
warning that it does contain flash
photography
the Home Secretary entry number 10 just
hours before she left government behind
quitting cabinet tonight swella bravaman
said she'd chosen to Tender her
resignation after breaking the
ministerial code by sending an official
document from her personal email but she
also went on the attack writing the
business of government relies upon
people accepting responsibility for
their mistakes pretending we haven't
made mistakes carrying on as if everyone
can't see that we've made them and
hoping that things will magically come
right is not serious politics I have
made a mistake I accept responsibility I
resign
after that dig at the PM the former Home
Secretary also went on to say the
government had broken key pledges and
she had serious concerns about honoring
Manifesto commitments
Liz truss's response was brief thanking
her home secretary and saying she looked
forward to working together in the
future but miss braverman's departures
only raised the temperature on this
embattled PM we've had both a Home
Secretary and the chancellor two of the
great offices of State both be replaced
in a space of six weeks no idea what the
government is doing on a whole series of
different issues and yet people across
the country who'll be worrying about
their Public Safety about the state of
the economy about National Security and
frankly people across the country
deserve better than this that is why we
need a change in government and the
prime minister's survival this chaos
missed shuts those changes happening and
fast 90 minutes later a familiar cabinet
face Grant shops back as Home Secretary
despite having spent the last month
criticizing number 10's policy platform
obviously it's been turbulent time for
the government but I think the most
important thing is to make sure that
people in this country know that they've
got security and that's why it's a great
honor to be appointed as Home Secretary
today I'm looking forward to getting
stuck into the role and providing the
the sort of security that the British
people need regardless of what's
Happening uh otherwise in in Westminster
what was unfolding in Westminster
remarkable a little bit of good behavior
for a moment on both sides of the house
as the wheels really came off the trust
government rumor swirling that the chief
whip in charge of government discipline
had quit after arguments submerged
between Tory MPS and the government over
a vote on fracking point of order tangum
Debonair there are rumors very strong
rumors that the government Chief whip
has apparently resigned I wonder if it's
possible to get some clarity is the
chief whip Mendy Morton still in post
um I'm not entirely clear on what the
situation is with the chief whip there
has been an element of confusion
earlier in the day there was at least an
attempt to focus all eyes on how the
Prime Minister was holding up fixing her
face
time to resign
is she prepared to battle for survival
at pmqs I am a fighter and not a quetter
up
I have acted in the National interest to
make sure that we have economic
stability an economy more stable than it
was but behind the calm surface of this
front bench things falling apart this a
government anything but stable it's not
an exaggeration to say that Westminster
is in shock after an unbelievably
chaotic day but these events are a
symptom of where we are now at the trust
Administration is barely fit for purpose
and how government appears to be in free
fall indeed a minister told me that the
situation is now to quote them utter
Madness while a former cabinet minister
said to me it's all heading in One
Direction it's just at what speed
a PM just six weeks in office and
already her MPS are working on who and
what comes next Beth Rigby Sky News
Westminster